living next to the wolson nuclear power
plant on south korea's east coast this
small group of neighbors has been
staging protests like this since 2014
and plans to expand the country's
nuclear power industry are adding to
their fears
protest organizer huang bun he claims
her diagnosis of thyroid cancer is a
direct result of radiation exposure
we can see the nuclear power plant from
here it's way too close i don't want to
see it anymore
she and her neighbors say their concerns
have gone unanswered by the government
what's more since president yun sukyol
took office in may south korea is set to
go ahead with an ambitious expansion in
nuclear power generation south korea
currently has 24 reactors but there are
plans for six more plants by 2036.
according to the government the
worldwide energy crisis made worse by
the war in ukraine should highlight the
need for more domestic power generation
especially in this growing industrial
giant that's hungry for electricity but
according to opponents the government
should be directing its efforts into
renewable energy instead
if they expend nuclear power and reduce
renewable energy for carbon neutrality
then it makes no progress on carbon
reduction rather the risks of nuclear
waste and accidents will increase quang
and her neighbors say tests have proven
they've been exposed to radiation but
the plant's operators say the levels of
radioactive tritium apparently detected
are well within safe limits
bananas contain potassium and we can be
exposed to radiation when we eat them
the maximum amount of tridium residents
can be exposed to is the same as eating
six bananas a year but as the world's
fifth biggest producer of nuclear power
embarked on a rapid expansion such
assurances aren't likely to ease
concerns for many living near to the new
plants rob mcbride al jazeera seoul